- Hey, I understand.
I mean, everybody's approach
to quarantine is different
and it's all relative in everybody's life.
But I understand your
approach to quarantine
was less toilet paper and more booze.
Is that right? (laughing)
- I couldn't believe it.
Well, like on day one of lockdown,
everywhere in the world
people going to supermarkets
and stockpiling toilet,
or fighting over toilet rolls.
How many do you need?
- I know.
- I just thought, that's ridiculous.
I would give up my last toilet
roll for a glass of beer.
(laughing)
If it's the end of the world,
I'd rather be drunk than
have lots of toilet rolls.
I just didn't get it.
- We're the same person.
I thought it was crazy, the
toilet paper crisis of 2020.
I was like, how 'bout food?
How 'bout ramen noodles?
- I know.
- Like something that'll last forever.
- It was such an arbitrary thing.
I've never, I'd never
thought about it before,
but it's such a...
But I mean, those people
who fighting on day one,
they're the sort of people
that if there was a plane crash,
they'd start eating other passengers.
I'd be going, "There's still sandwiches."
(laughing)
"We've still got some,
don't eat this plane."
- Or crackers. (laughing)
- Yeah, yeah.
No, put the leg down.
- Well something I love that
you've done in quarantine,
is there a badminton court at your house?
- Yes, yes.
I thought we've got a garden,
and then we found a badminton
set we hadn't opened
in one of those cupboards
that you do for like 10 years.
We put it up.
Then we ordered some
spray chalk from Amazon
and we put out the markings,
and now we play badminton everyday.
Yeah, so that's really been great, yeah.
- Amazing.
Like who goes for, you don't play catch,
you don't do like a normal, that's just so
like farfetched of a sport. (laughing)
- It is, it's not a
sport that I would have,
you know, played in school in stuff.
Also, there's a lot of
bending over in badminton.
Because with tennis I can do the thing
where I get the ball up.
But there's a lot of bending
over to pick the shuttlecock up
because it doesn't bounce.
And I'm getting to that age now
where I make a noise when I bend over
and have to stand up.
That (pained groaning).
So (laughing) -
- I do that, too.
I'm 38, whatever.
(laughing)